[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
en este momento gracias a este ejercicio
de neuro plástica que acabamos de hacer
su cerebro está en un grado de vibración
de frecuencia de ondas
y de alguna manera esto es experimentar
lo que acabamos de experimentar es un
estado de flor colectivo gracias
a la sensación de armonía positiva que
nos da la unidad
en este nivel de vibración o de
frecuencia
podemos desarrollar el pensamiento
profundo podemos desarrollar actividades
motrices avanzadas
y procesos de integración mental
a un muy alto nivel de la misma manera
dependiendo de las actividades que
tengamos podríamos estar en una
frecuencia de vibración de ondas delta
que eso es por ejemplo estamos en un
estado de sueño profundo donde también
encontramos los tonos vocales son esos
puntos de sueño profundo
y si la frecuencia aumenta llegamos a
las ondas theta un estado de relajación
relacionado con la meditación un estado
abierto tranquilo
por otro lado la atención general o las
actividades que ustedes hacen en su vida
cotidiana se relacionan con la
frecuencia alfa
la beta que acabamos de experimentar y
más allá en el rango humano tenemos la
frecuencia gamma
que son ondas que todavía nos cuesta a
los seres humanos en este plano alcanzar
ahora bien me interesa que nos
enfoquemos en lo que sucede con las tres
frecuencias de la mitad de toda esta
este rango
porque esto es justamente donde está el
espectro de vibración humana consciente
es decir cuando ustedes analizan
exactamente qué en las ondas delta
estamos en una relajación profunda o en
un sueño profundo y las ondas gamma son
difíciles de alcanzar nuestra conciencia
se reduce a las ondas theta beta y alfa
ahora como es un asunto de vibración de
lo que les quiero hablar de este estado
de flow y ya haremos la conexión con el
tema de la resiliencia quiero que
analicemos
qué pasa con la onda y esto es algo que
ustedes tal vez conocen
inmediatamente cuando analizamos la onda
tenemos ese valle y esa cresta
y es ahí justamente donde nuestro plano
encontramos el tema de la polaridad
y esto es algo que es un poco complejo
desde mi perspectiva porque tenemos esa
necesidad de alguna manera hemos sido
educados en estar entre polaridades y es
naturales es código binario de alguna
manera de vibración estamos entre una
cosa y otra el día la noche la
naturaleza es así sin embargo lo que
sucede es que normalmente tenemos una
tendencia a estancar nos por ir
demasiado al extremo de la polaridad y
es ahí donde empezamos a tener de alguna
manera situaciones adversas
con el lenguaje pasa mucho por ejemplo
cuando uno dice pues tengo un problema
la palabra problema por ejemplo
por qué no intentar hacer un ejercicio y
empezar a modificar a nivel cognitivo
eso y por ejemplo no cambiar eso por la
palabra reto
sólo como una idea ahora a nivel del
estado de flow
el concepto que entiendo por esta
necesidad de flujo es el de trascender
la dicotomía de la polaridad
es decir evitar que estemos yendo entre
los picos de la emoción y la tristeza y
todas estas emociones y lograr de alguna
manera un movimiento consciente
evolutivo relajado y abierto con alguna
connotación positiva idealmente
entonces aquí está el reto que tenemos
hoy y es si estamos hablando de
vibración y de polaridad quiero
invitarlos a una sesión muy corta de
meta aprendizajes de aprender cómo
aprender vamos a hacer una pequeña
reprogramación cognitiva
[Aplausos]
quiero tener y traer a colación
rápidamente el concepto de teoría de
cuerdas
y en teoría de cuerdas lo que sucede es
que es una teoría que plantea unificar
los conceptos de la física tradicional y
de la física cuántica y explicar en una
sola teoría cómo se unen todas las leyes
de la naturaleza es decir cómo logramos
unir explicar la gravedad el
electromagnetismo y las fuerzas
nucleares
pero más allá de lo que plantea la
teoría de cuerdas quiero enfocarme hoy
en dos conceptos el primero y quiero
ponerlos a pensar un poco con esto el
concepto del multiverso y simplemente
quiero que piensen en lo que esta
palabra puede ser para ustedes
multiverso hemos crecido en esa
necesidad de hablar del universo y de la
totalidad del universo pero el
multiverso a través de teoría de cuerdas
abre una gama de posibilidades infinitas
y si lo analizamos en la naturaleza y en
nuestro cuerpo nivel fisiológico estamos
compuestos por una cantidad de elementos
y vibraciones
por qué no comenzar a pensar multiverse
al mente
ahora no me quiero quedar allá quiero
introducir un segundo concepto que
considero fascinante y que ayuda
muchísimo no sólo al estado de flores y
no a la conciencia resiliente tiene que
ver con la matriz multidimensional no
quiero quedarme en términos técnicos
simplemente entiendan esto como el campo
de posibilidades
entonces el ejercicio ahora es tener un
punto de partida un punto
llamémoslo y un punto b en el espectro
también y vamos a hacer un ejercicio
bidimensional imaginen una cuadrícula en
un papel ubiquen su punto a directamente
arriba su punto b y traten de establecer
una manera de llegar al punto b sin
establecer una línea directa
cada uno tiene una posibilidad de llegar
a ese punto de maneras distintos y eso
es exactamente lo que la matriz
multidimensional explica la posibilidad
de adherirse
un campo infinito de opciones a un
multiverso de opciones
entonces cómo hacemos para entrar en ese
estado de flor consciente
recordar primero que cada frecuencia y
cada momento incluso este en el que
están ustedes es el punto de partida
para una matriz multidimensional de
opciones en la vida
en muchas maneras de ver y entender la
vida no olviden eso
y quiero compartirles tres sets de
herramientas para entrar en el flow
consciente
y lo primero tiene que ver con elevar la
vibración positiva consciente y cuando
hablo de vibración es un tema de alguna
manera un poco coloquial
pensémoslo desde el punto de vista de
frecuencia también de impulso eléctrico
entonces
aquí está una lista de alternativas a la
que los invito
número 1
estar constantemente en un estado de
relajación
tener una actitud constante hacia el
aprendizaje
ser flexible
4 reconocer en qué puntos o espacios de
mi vida hay tensión o bloqueos
energéticos y esto puede ser a nivel
emocional de pareja a nivel sexual a
nivel de proyectos financieros dónde
están esos bloqueos esos estancamientos
quinto tratar esos estancamientos
desarrollando limpiezas conscientes de
la energía y la vibración de su realidad
sexto
contagiarse de personas y de actitudes y
de situaciones donde hay vibraciones
positivas cosas que le hacen bien a su
ser
y séptimo lograr estar en contacto con
actividades que permiten la creatividad
y el gozo
entonces con esto empezamos a crecer
nuestro nivel consciente positivo de
vibración y es ahí donde vengo a
introducir un concepto que me fascina a
mí y es el concepto de él
la acción multidimensional entonces aquí
voy a trabajar con el rango de las ondas
theta alfa y beta y específicamente los
picos de theta y beta para sugerirles
actividades donde podemos encontrar ese
flow
actividades lentos
la respiración
lenta y consciente la meditación el yoga
el tai chi chi cong
tomar agua de manera consciente
estas actividades el caminar el darse
una ducha caliente en forma consciente
elevan la vibración de las ondas theta
y en el otro grado de la escala están
las ondas de vibración beta y entonces
un ejercicio les pregunto qué libro
están leyendo en este momento
qué nuevo idioma están aprendiendo en
este momento qué nuevo instrumento
musical están aprendiendo ahora
qué actividad motriz fina desarrollan
constantemente están bailando
continuamente
y todo esto eleva el espectro cognitivo
en el cerebro porque trabaja con puntos
muy específicos neuronales que
desarrollan conexiones
entonces el tener este espectro de la
acción multidimensional es el segundo
set de herramientas hacia el estado de
flor
ahora no embargo empezamos haciendo
ejercicio de percusión corporal he
descubierto en los últimos diez años de
mi vida que es una de las herramientas
más increíbles y con mayor potencial
para el desarrollo cognitivo humano
entonces ya saben a tocar percusión
corporal
y ahora más allá de eso entonces la
pregunta sería
como entramos de manera consciente en el
flow y esta es mi última lista para
ustedes me gusta mi invitación
primero
observar
ante una situación simplemente observar
segundo no permitir que la mente
reactiva tome el control de su realidad
en ese momento
pasa mucho que recibimos la situación y
con mi inmediatamente nos enganchamos
con eso empecé a tener una actitud mucho
más tranquila después de eso viene el
análisis nuevamente de esta matriz
llamémoslo multidimensional de
posibilidades analicen desde ese espacio
las opciones que tienen sin ser
reactivos
y una vez uno analiza entonces puede
meterse el cuento de reconocer y escoger
las opciones que vibran de una manera
positiva para ustedes una vez hecho esto
entramos directamente en la acción y
entramos en esa dirección de evolución a
permitir que se complete el ciclo y
vamos de las primeras cuatro el observar
la mente reactiva el análisis y
reconocer de ondas theta a ondas beta en
un salto cuántico inmediato cuando
tomamos la acción
piensen en esto estas herramientas
pueden ayudar a ese estado de flor para
terminar no quiero irme sin dar la clave
de lo que considero que es
realmente donde encontramos y podemos
entender ese concepto del flow y viene
del espacio
en el espacio están todas las respuestas
a nivel cuántico
el nivel de vida
en el espacio de su fuego personal
encuentra en su misión
mi misión
es ayudarle a la gente a entender el
ritmo
en qué parte de su flow personal que
parte de su misión están
no olviden sin embargo
que más allá del punto en el que estén
podemos y vamos a trascender
porque somos y estamos
en flow
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias